everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're continuing
our coverage of the second tournament
the grand prix 2019 this one's being
held in Latvia we are in round 3 which
means there are four players left and
each of the grand prix tournaments there
are 16 players and they play heads up
against one opponents they play a best
of two series and then the winner will
move on if there's a tie they go to tie
breakers but we are down to four playing
heads up and then we will have a finals
after this round three the four people
left alive and abhishek MVL shaq your
mama dia and wesley so today we're gonna
be looking at a game from Shakira and
Wesley so Shakira playing the white
pieces and Wesley so playing the black
pieces so we'll go ahead and get into it
starts out with d4 Knight to f6 c4 pawn
e6 not f3 and then after pend e5 pawn g3
so this is the Catalan opening the open
classical line in the Catalan opening we
don't see as much Catalan opening
nowadays always good to see it at these
high level play Bishop to e7 Bishop g2 a
castle on the kingside castle and then
the pawn takes on c4 and this is really
the thought behind the opening for white
giving up this pawn early into the game
this lights for a bishop being here on
g2 controls this entire light square
diagonal and because the pawns no longer
blocking it depending on where this
Knight moves to this can really hamper
blacks development on the Queen side of
the board which usually in this opening
you're gonna castle on the King side
then you're gonna look to develop on the
Queen side right away this does stop
that but now there's a few ways that
white can come back and get this
material if he wants to play Queen to c2
this is pretty common Knight to a3 at
some point attack in this pond it's very
difficult for black to hold on to this
pawn here as far as the material so
although white has given up some
material can always get back that
material at some point decides to not
worry about the material right away
continues with this plan of developing
quicker than his opponents his opponent
does have that move down that he gave up
to capture
this material right here tonight to e5
this also attacks the pawn on c4 what so
decides to go and bring Knight to c6
which after the recapture here very easy
for just Bishop takes on c6 and this is
the most common that I would expect for
anyone playing in this variation other
things you could see would be pawn b3
this is this is one option although
you're not gonna see it too often you
could always get the Queen involved into
the game if you want to but really
Bishop to c6 this is why you play this
what I was not expecting to see is what
Jack here played and that is Knight to
a3 yes this is attacking the pond but
you're essentially just telling your
opponent to take here on a three which
is what Wesley so does and then after
the recapture you now have double pawns
on the a file
interesting move definitely don't see
this all too often after pawn takes on a
3 we see Bishop to a6 and the main
reason we see Bishop to a6 is once to
hold on to the material as much as
possible Bishop to b7 doesn't really do
a whole heck of a lot Queen to a4 this
is now double attacking this pawn here
the bishop on g2 still attacking the
pawn now the Queen attacking but then
this is also attacking the pawn on c4 so
yeah if you want to try to hold on to
this maybe with your queen you're still
going to lose this material right here
you can't bring your Queen down to d5 it
would fall to the bishop on a g2 so
because that black breath recognizes and
just decides okay I can't hold on to
this pawn right here I'll go and bring
my Bishop down to a6 try to hold on to
the pawn on c4 Queen to d2 rook b8 says
let's just try to control this open file
here Queen to a5 attacking the bishop
rook comes down to b6 defending this
bishop right here pawn to a4 Queen to d6
just centralizing the Queen had a few
options could have also played Queen to
e7 and swung is rook over here to d8
trying to control the semi open file but
Queen to d6 definitely a good
centralizing move for the Queen making
sure that the most
piece right here is involved they can
always swing his rook over here to d8 if
he wants to pawn to a3 rook to be a
doubling up on at the B file here and
then e for and this is a critical place
into the game White's
now looking to push up in the board
after pawn to e4 he's threatening the
move pawn to e5 which I think is a
critical move to try to avoid with this
I would expect to see Queen to d7 we did
not see that in the game we saw the move
pawn c3 now this is a discovered attack
with the bishop taking on the rook on f1
but I'm not sure that this is the
approach that Wesley so wants to go down
pawn to e5 is exactly what we see the
Queen comes back doesn't want that's a
fall the Knights gonna fall first this
idea I got to go ahead and take that
Bishop takes on f1 Bishop recaptures do
not want to recapture with your kinks
always looking at how sides are going to
recapture is important if the King takes
then Queen comes down capture the pawn
here on d4 and this is really
threatening the move Queen to d1 check
me there's no real way to stop this
maybe King to g1 rook down b1 this is
threatening first taking here but if
there is a recapture now this is
threatening rook to c1 there's no real
great way to stop this there there could
be lots of variations here but at the
end of day it's not going to in
extremely well for whites if we come
back you do not want to take not with
the King there and so rightfully took
with the bishop on f1 poncey 2 tries to
save things but really it's just not
that great of a move this pawn is going
to fall it was putting a lot of pressure
and was well defended now it's just
going to be a lost piece here rook to a2
Queen comes down on d5 we do see the
exchange right here pond recapture so it
does help the pawn chain a little bit
knowing that the pawns gonna be
recaptured no longer has double or
triple pawns as he had on the C file but
after the pawn recaptures this is
getting into the endgame both sides have
good amount of material but you can see
here that white has some pretty active
pieces and usually if you have two rooks
that's gonna be extremely good but you
don't want so many ponds on the board
these rooks really gonna have to work
together if Wesley so wants to end up
with a good end game from white
standpoint these bishops are gonna be
able to move around the board more so
than the rooks because of rooks are just
blocked off by all the ponds on the
board rook takes on c7 to equalize as
far as the pawns but since he has two
bishops bishops generally being worth
three points the rooks being worth five
points the White's up slightly from a
material standpoint black also has the
double pawns here on the F file so White
has a small advantage gonna come down to
Wesley so if he can get his double rooks
use them to his advantage and see if he
can pick off some of these ponds get
into the endgame in a much favorable
position weston so continues with rook
to b7 work down here c5 King g7 both
sides getting their kings involved into
the game now that the Queen's are off
the board Bishop to b5 and this is a
really good square because it blocks off
these two rooks from working with each
other and as soon as they can no longer
work together it's gonna be very
difficult for Wesley so to find a win
here the bishop is being defended by the
rook can't really do too much tries to
swing over here to a1 to pick off this
pawn rook to c3 now playing double duty
here defending both the pawn on a three
and the bishop on a c1 rook to b6 a
bishop to f4 just centralizing that
knowing that wasn't really doing too
much here on c1 wants to start to attack
some of the squares that black could go
to King that three getting involved into
the game work to D one knowing that's
not gonna threaten this pawn right here
wants to start attacking some of the
other material Bishop to e3 defending
that material rook over here b1 but it's
all by himself there's just no way for
this rook to do anything King to g4 rook
to h1 attacking the pawn pawn h4 king g6
now the bishop centralizes with d3
and then pawn f5 King to f3 work over
here d1 just attacking the pawn but it's
still defendant can't really do too much
pawn F excuse me g4 and at this pot spot
Wesley so decides to go ahead and resign
wish you were to played a little bit
longer yes he is down as far as material
but not by much and yes he does need to
get his rooks playing a little bit
better together cuz right now they're
guro going around trying to attack and
you know white just has so much material
to defend against one so rook here but
it's not an easy endgame you could
definitely have your opponent make a
small mistake and you could find a draw
here Wesley so decides not so much today
and resigns hoping that he can come back
tomorrow but he does have his work cut
out for him any time a player knows that
all they have to do is go in and get a
draw to move on to the finals it's just
much easier for preparation many players
when they take a line in an opening they
try to keep themselves pretty open
because they don't know if their
opponents can make a mistake and they
want to have some chances to win if they
do if you know you're gonna draw you can
play specific lines that are very draw
and hard for your opponent's ever find
anything because you play these many
times over it and you know there's
there's no way for you to win but
there's also very limited ways for your
opponent to win so Shakir
congratulations to him on the victory
today it's gonna be going in tomorrow
looking for at least a draw and he will
be moving on to the finals in the other
game Alexander gonna shoot can NBL they
did draw so if someone wins tomorrow
they will also be going into the finals
thank you guys so much for watching at
this game and we will be back tomorrow
for round number three game number two
thanks for watching